this machine might be the best jumper
on earth
it's 30 centimeters high but can leap
more than 30 meters into the air
three times the current world record for
a jumping robot
and it does it using unnatural
engineering
many robots use designs based in biology
the best jumpers the animal kingdom has
to offer have a plethora of ways to
maximize their leaps like long limbs
strong muscles and extended joints
some insects like grasshoppers even use
a form of power amplification to exceed
the limitations of their muscles
stretching specialized elastic rods in
their exoskeletons that launched them
when released
but as diverse as the natural world is
evolution hasn't cracked every option
and there is something that machines can
do that nature can't
work multiplication even the most
powerful muscles only offer a single
stroke of action meanwhile machines can
use mechanisms like ratcheting or
rotating to build up a store of energy
before releasing
now a team of researchers have
investigated the differences between
engineered and biological jumpers and
took those insights to create a device
capable of jumping
32.9 meters that's taller than the
statue of christ the redeemer in brazil
the jumper uses a small motor to reel in
a polyethylene line compressing springs
made of an advanced hybrid material
then a lightweight release mechanism
unlatches to launch the device skywards
simple but each element has been finely
tuned and honed to maximize jumping
performance from lightweight feet
designed to better transmit energy at
launch
to a shape that morphs into an
aerodynamic dart
according to the team behind the jumper
this design might be near the
mathematical limit of jump height using
available materials
and this isn't just an exercise in cool
robot design
jumping is potentially a useful mode of
transportation especially in situations
where flight is impossible for instance
if there's no atmosphere
indeed jumping mechanisms have already
been used in space
in 2018 the jaxa hayabusa 2 mission
landed two different hopping rovers on
the asteroid ryugu their jumping prowess
allowed them to maneuver around the
rocky environment with less risk of
getting stuck than would face a wheeled
rover
the designers of this device estimate
that on the surface of the moon it could
leap an astonishing 125 meters high and
travel half a kilometer in a single
bound
so perhaps the next giant leap in space
exploration will be taken by a
mechanical jumper like this one